I do.
I, I know that we have a lot of stressful
things going on.
As of this moment, we don't know who is going
to be the next president of the United States,
but I want to take a moment just to say something
happy.
We had an incredible turnout of force in the
independent progressive media community yesterday.
We set records on every platform.
Our we estimate that one point five million
different people watched some part of our
election results coverage last night.
We had over up to 82, 83000 live concurrent
viewers on YouTube with a sum total of about
one point four million different people coming
in and out throughout the evening.
A record for us, incredible ungodly numbers
of comments and and messages from everybody,
just completely unbelievable.
We had four to 7000 people throughout the
night on Twitch, which is another platform
that we've been taking very seriously.
It's been a great place to do politics, not
historically, not the place for politics,
more for gaming and other types of content.
We are there and a few others are there doing
politics on Twitch.
An incredible night in total view time by
far a record on Twitch, 400 paid subscribers
signing up via the Twitch platform, another
400 members signing up on our website.
So the this is what what matters is do we
remove Donald Trump?
And we don't know that yet.
But the way that our community has come out
and spent the evening with us and with me,
it was a long night.
It was a stressful night during which I tried
to encourage people to to remain calm.
But what an incredible evening.
And now the question is, can we continue?
If the goal is the idea would be that if we
can remove Donald Trump, we still don't know.
We're still waiting on results if Trump can
be removed.
My goal would be the dream would be that all
of this growth that we've been experiencing
gives us a much stronger position from which
to now do progressive activism.
If we remove Donald Trump, we've been playing
a lot of defense the last four years.
We may have to play defense for another four.
By the time you watch today's show or listen
to this clip, you might already know the winner,
but the opportunity is if we can remove Donald
Trump to leverage our larger than ever audience.
Thanks to you.
Thanks to you really to get the most we can
out of whatever opportunity presents itself
to move things to the left in the United States.
So a huge, huge thank you.
Again, our estimate, more than one point five
million different people joined us on YouTube,
twitch our Facebook stream.
And we were also the live Facebook stream
for our broadcast partner, free speech TV.
Really, really incredible.
So we're going to continue counting vote counting
votes at some point in the next day.
Two, three, four days, we will have a likely
winner.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you, for
you today.
I'm told Pat barely slept.
So we will hear from him.
We're going to look at what we do know from
yesterday, including ballot initiatives, including
some of the key Senate and House races, and
so much more about what to expect in the coming
sort of like of the day, the week, the two
and a half months until January 20th and the
next four years.
Those are the different time frames that we're
looking at right now.
So come on in.
Grab yourself a membership at Join Pakman
Dotcom.
It takes very little time.
You'll get instant access to the members only
bonus show and there is much to discuss.
So I look forward to seeing you that.